So I am the Regis professor of chemistry at University of Glasgow.
I run a pretty big research group exploring complex chemistry
and I try to think about how things got started in chemistry and biology and how to make.
Ways to explore all of chemistry. And. Is that one of our questions that you ask yourself.
Yeah I think the question I ask myself a law is is why. And I suppose link to that how. Did.
Basically the Earth become a living.
And I am an inorganic chemist and the word inorganic is associated with dead or nonliving
and organic chemistry is associated with living.
So the question I asked almost to make fun or to describe it clearly is how did Death chemistry become living
or how did it in organic world become organic. Put simply where did biology come from on earth.
So what's the difference between Or can you see.
Well with that I can answer that in in a very complex way in a very simple way
but I would say that biology uses organic chemistry.
And it's able to build machines based on organic chemistry and the ultimate machine that biology is built.
Is the organic chemist because then they can make more molecules
but this is a rotter robot argument I'll talk about later
but biology predominately is based upon organic chemistry it's a very nice chemistry or your D.N.A.
or That all the proteins all your muscles all built with what organic chemistry and some inorganic stuff some salt
and all that to make it work. So that may question you use right of ours. How create life from there. Yeah absolutely.
Imagine back to when. Planet Earth got started.
It was probably a fairly busy place asteroids meteorites love Earth thunder lightning but it was dead.
I think of it like a beach like sand on a beach where there was nothing but the wind blowing around and
when I say peoples.
How does that sound on the beach in organic dead stuff turned into a living stuff to see we fish to the trees to the
grass to the bacteria. What on earth happened. Literally warbird happened.
Is quite an interesting question because put so simply.
It's a chemist ultimate dream like this is the question what turned a dead chemistry into living chemistry.
The question for me. Why do you raise this question. Well I'm not the first to raise a question.
Lots of people raise a question in their own way in their own way.
I guess we all have a what is the meaning question don't we.
And we all whether you're an artist or a composer or you're a filmmaker or. An architect.
I guess we all there is all meaning and in the things that we build
and create for me I am really fascinated by the fact that chemistry is extremely complicated is that organic chemistry
is complicated. The way the biology works disease works molecules work complicated.
And I can do stuff with my hands and my eyes but it's complicated.
So if I purposefully build something I'm controlling my fingers I can see my world. But what happened.
How did that work without me. And so I wondered what are the steps. What are the simple steps that lead to complexity.
So for me it's kind of that manifestation of.
Although I'm a chemist I don't really understand very much chemistry it seems quite complex.
And I'd like to know where we start. Yeah because now you're at. This complex. Where to start.
If you travel answer that question. Oh gosh. I guess in my in the laboratory.
I was always fascinated how I could make molecules make themselves.
So what we try to do this is think would know technology another technology is bigger than a molecule.
But smaller than say a second Pandora a spring in a very fine watch.
So how can I get molecules to go into that nano world because I can make nano machines.
If I can make them in machines and I had all sorts of fascinating things.
So as an organic chemist I basically took sand stuff with simpler sand and all ideas I added acid to it.
And when I added acid to certain sands they turned into nano objects
and I was fascinated how could those nano objects build themselves and part of the training I got
when I was doing my Ph D. and Then after my Ph D.
Was explaining
and exploring the self-assembly of sand literally how could the Sand Castle build itself without the bucket.
How could the grains of sand know that each other. Existed to build the castle.
And I spent a lot of time looking at that and maybe because I look back in time.
It's easy for me to kind of say ah I was always interested in the origin of life and making new life
but I guess it started with a fascinating of just complexity in general how could the castle build itself without a
person or a bucket. So it might. Go out itself. You know and that's really got to go.
Yeah and well it's not well of course the house built itself.
If you allow the human being to be because there really thing is now I say to people who are seven forty seven is too
complicated to spontaneously assemble so many yes so there is a problem with probability and there is a pro.
I'm with complexity. If you say to him as a mathematician or a statistician that something is complex.
They would translate that to as being improbable to happen on its own I think they're wrong.
I think it's not just improbable I think the chances it happening is zero.
So I think the chances of him for some improbable things happening here.
I just put a number on it makes him feel better. But with a seven forty seven.
There is a zero chance of seven forty seven one assembler self.
However have an origin of life have human beings make a seven forty seven. They then the human being.
Plus the technology makes the seven forty seven. So clearly the probably isn't zero because seven forty seven is exist.
And I think that's about this house the house didn't form itself a person did it. So when you then think about life.
And life is a very interesting thing because it's a machine that can act on surroundings to conquer It's almost like
for me. Living Matter is somehow superior to dead matter because it can literally.
I'm on my bike I don't feel like quite. So so for me it's really interesting about in slave stuff going on.
So this house did not deal with itself a human being.
Did OK what built a human being and that's why I go down from there and then you backwards and backwards and backwards.
Down to say what is the simplest thing that could happen by chance it could make more sophisticated things happen.
So this is where all the notion of complexity came from in the House
and the person I often have say one thing which is no origin of life. No biology. No biology no biologist.
No biologist no human being. No you know philosophy. No philosophy.
I'll try and say it in a bit of a more elegant way later but it.
That's kind of interesting and so quit essentially what I'm saying is that you
and I we human beings we see the world and we make a pact we we understand the world we we perceive it.
So what is it about the stuff in me the atoms in me that allow me to appreciate the world that is a really interesting
phase transition the sand in that castle is not aware of itself.
But you add some complexity to it and a few billion years of evolution and you have a not only human being.
Where how did that happen. So I think it's a step in complexity and so what.
And I mean we can go right down to the history of it but describe complexes of this research.
So you find that there are parts. Yes So mice.
So there's lots of I don't if you want to go down this part depending I let you die I mean if you.
Let's go back to the origin of life for people often talk about trying to work out the origin of life.
I think it's a really important problem.
There is more money and time being spent on the origin of the universe and the origin of mass I.E.
That's how he exposed on in gravity than the origin of life. There is never been a big project for the origin of life.
But if I could understand where life came from or if I could this is my objective to make new life in my lab.
I could then tell you if life alien life is possible the constraints of a new life forms
and I could expand the chemistry the chemical space beyond what we know already.
And we could talk about the Shadow biosphere in new types of life forms.
So that's a really important problem the problem of the origin of life is that it's historical question.
So lots of people go back and say.
First assumption origin of life took billions of years of well everyone saying well no. Maybe just a billion.
So why billion chemistry occurs much faster than the billion years. Evolution takes a long time we know that.
Then when you think about the problem.
So if complex chemistry didn't take a billion years how long one hundred million two hundred men in. What about a year.
What about if you could go from sand to a primitive cell with a year. What would that change can then then you say OK.
People say that's impossible. And then you say why.
And they said well origin of life was clearly improbable clearly impossible we are clearly a fluke.
We are clearly an accident. But that that's also a very that's not tested. So the fact we are here.
The first assumption I make is that we're easy life is easier than you think. Where we are easy. Are you for life.
Or you know I home or NO NO NO WAY I will. No no no. So I think there are three problems I'm really interested in.
First of all is how to make a new life form.
The second one is how can that life a single So how does it is a single cell
or something then how does that life form become cooperative to make a multi cellular creature.
Because actually that took a billion years that did take a very long time.
Could we speed it up and thirdly what happens to that multicellular creature to make intelligent had to have a brain
and then have sensors. So I think the origin of life might be much easier than we think.
Multicellularity might just take time.
And then the real magic might be how we get to intelligence but I just would like to I'm a chemist
and I would just like to answer the sand cell question or the dead to life. First.
And I don't have a hundred million years I don't maybe have a thousand years I might have ten years or twenty years.
So what can I do in my laboratory to speed that up and one assumptions can I make
and if I make those assumptions about time and complexity.
Does it allow me to say something really obvious like why you know what let's say it was simple
and let's assume it took me time. No to no time.
What do we then do that opens up the entire chemical space so that you step back and visualize your.
What is happening there. What are you. What both your question. Wow. What am I doing in my lab or yeah. So my lab.
Now is really exciting because it combines expertise I've been dreaming of getting together for a decade
or actually probably as long as. For thirty two years since I was ten years old.
Because it combines people who can play with computers combines robotics. It combines chemistry.
It can it can be combined vision.
And what we're trying to do in one half a lab is we're trying to really good chemistry to make new molecules.
And the other half a laboratory to build robots that would do really simple chemistry to build really simple molecules
and we're trying to say Look at that chemist over there. They're amazing. Look at that come that robot over there.
That's really dumb.
How can we how can we make the robot A smart as a smart chemist
and what does that mean is there something that can the robot that can do a simple that can get smarter.
And so at the moment we've got a number of approaches the first approach is what I call bottom up sand to sand castle.
So we are basically shaking the sand in a bucket. And we're hoping that the grain.
Collect together to build something miraculous.
And we can do it to some degree but only small miracles no big miracles
and we're finding something really interesting that small miracles can have bigger miracles
and have bigger miracles so this is like what we call a template based self-assembly if you make if you think of a I
want to make an arch right in a bridge and want to make a bridge across the river one way doing is to build an arch.
But to build an arch you need a template for the arch you can made out of wood
but what if I could make the template of. Art form. Spontaneously to film The Bridge.
That's kind of nice and sunny the arch built the bridge in my lap or try to make sure that we can do that
and we found a way of a molecule makes his own archway and then it makes the bridge and then the archway dissolves.
And when you see it the bridge and the game is like going. Where the bridge come from.
I didn't build the arch and we caught the archway.
Literally with his trousers down by accident like that snapshot and then we understood that.
So that's what we called bottom up. For example that one. Of the obvious that you're right about. Yeah yeah. It got so.
Involved.
You know I mean the ground the grain of sand grain of sand just to get that same cast of made up of sand
and all to make a sand castle you can do one of two things you could position each the sand with a microscope.
By hand by hand and take you a long time you could get a bucket with the right indentations
and just scoop the sand to put it in there or you could program the sand to self-assembly like ants. And somehow.
How do you what are the smallest rules you can come up with is a bit like trying to work out those rules. So another.
Much way. Yeah. So. So hard. One another archway that would do itself spontaneously.
Well it's from us that it's a bit like us some making a snowman.
So we made a snowman outside of my son the other day and it's a bit like um.
Ask no man was made up of four snow balls and we started rolling the snow together to make a big ball.
So we just rolled the snow for maybe ten minutes me got a ball that was basically half a metre stop.
Then we wrote roll it for less time and we got maybe a quarter of a meter. Put on top and another one.
For basically half of a quarter of a metre on top. So we have a fat. Less fat.
So its name is so he has a way of doing it to say could I allow a stone at the top of the hill to roll down the hill
get enough snow to become a big ball and then split into two to make another ball
and then they would assemble at the bottom.
It could happen randomly if you did enough times and that and all
and that's what we're kind of doing in the lab setting up random snowballs to make say ah there's a snowman.
But there's a snowman can we let the Can we try enough times for in the stone round down the hill so gravity plus no
roll snowball snowman. Now the interesting thing is you need to make that simple enough.
And then but then when the snowman is able to build itself. This is in the magic this is when life stars.
So what is the minimum thing you can do to make some think they can make itself. So what isn't.
Is there is like how can you start the ball rolling quite literally. And this is so this is the bottom up.
But that's very hard. We don't know where to search and you're quite right to be confused but.
Is a big probably probability. I'm How many lottery tickets too I have to play until I win.
So that's bottom up top down is me being control I'm building robots.
That I will control to build everything like atom by atom.
And what we do is we then asked every give the robot the instructions we give it some knowledge some information.
So we say the robot and we say to one robot your dumb make a molecule make a snap make a snowman keep going.
How many goes how many goes how many goes we take another I can't say he's a picture of a snowman.
Make it so the robot cars are made ready. Then when we look at the robot you say OK that's really good snowman.
We're now going to remove some of the information but we still want you to make a snowman.
How much information can we take away.
So this is like top down and what we're trying to do is work out how much information do we need to know.
And how much can we find. And this whole concept of information in biology.
So there's a bit like how much randomness can we use or how much complexity can we get from our environment
and it just goes back to an observation about biology. Biology that all living things are made of cells..
And in every cell. There is D.N.A. And the D.N.A. Allows the cell to evolve but no D.N.A. No evolution. D.N.A.
Is complicated. So where did the D.N.A. Come from.
So what we're trying to do is look at the robots to help us guess that.
And that's what we do in the lab so we have two extremes we have the random class get lucky and no random.
Let's Big Brother it.
So we have like our big brother robot the videos everything and orchestrate so we have the conductor
and we have the free form no conductor. And. So you go on the same time we.
Going on in the group at the same time and we using common people to look at the experiments Yeah yeah so. Of.
All right there is a problem here. With the lock. How you managed to direct the work. So he's a thing.
One of the big time things that chemists are beginning to understand. It's like spread betting.
Spread betting you go best you go on a horse.
You can bet on the winner or the loser or you can spread on a variety of outcomes and say right.
I'll get money that way. I won't make money as fast but I'll make money if your objective is like that. I give you.
I don't know how many euro's or pounds I write your objective is to double your money in two hours.
You could if you were lazy you could say right.
All on one horse and you'd be dead or all when in very quickly when you say OK I'm not sure but I'll make a spread.
And so one of the things that we try to do is look at how we can look at the distribution of different.
How we can spread our luck. So you can do that by doing lots of things at once. So what I'm trying to say is.
Time is the enemy. Because it to get lucky you need to wait times if you do want to time. It will take a long time.
If you want to use the same amount of time we get lucky quickly you spread back in my lap.
We don't have that much time so we spread bets like parallel.
And what we're trying to do is to say OK we want to set up a series of random experiments.
But we want to because we can because we could do the experiment in one big say a swimming pool sized reactor.
Or we could do it in a very small cup or a test tube. We could do it in a smaller. If we have lots of small test tubes.
Then we could do lots of different experiments in the same space as maybe at swimming pool so suddenly one swimming
pool could be cut up into one million or even more test tubes. Suddenly we have a million goes where we had one.
Now take into a droplet like an oil droplet you get in your salad dressing.
And we to do all the experiments one oil droplet per experiment. Suddenly you can do it.
Trillion experiments where you only have one.
So you have a tremendous
and then very quickly you can calculate how many times do I need to play the lottery before I get lucky and in the U.K.
I think a few weeks ago to win the thirty three million probability I think was something like two hundred fifty six
million to one CO with a trillion I can do that over four times here I go I win I have four top four chances of winning
in that experiment and that is how we do it. Go all most important question that you.
BLOCK OK that before I define life rotate if I'm going to find something else because it's really important to
understand why definition is useful. Many scientists think that life cannot be defined.
And I think that is unhelpful for trying to explain it to other people and also to try
and get a concept because sometimes defining a concept we don't quite understand it.
The one I like is flight imagine before humans flew they said write what is flight and you go outside.
Look at birds fly.
Maybe you might look at those squirrels that can glide or bumble bees
and you can say OK this is I have this notion of flying there is some do work against gravity
and they can move there and they go in the air but when the first airplane was made by the Wright brothers or whoever.
They flew a few yards. That wasn't very far but then we went our flight is powered. Heavier than air travel.
Not just balloon flying. And because I could go one hundred yards.
Now I worked out how I could go a thousand yards and then
when I'm in a thousand yards I want to cross the Atlantic before you know it.
We got we know what flight is for me fly is getting on an airplane going up into the sky coming down again safely
and being our travel several thousand miles in the air about touching down. And I think by framing it this way.
If we define life in a similar way it might help us because now flight takes off in different forms.
We have rockets we have planes we have gliders we have we may even have all sorts of other ways of doing helicopters.
So when it comes to what life is life seems to be a an object when you feed it it reparative multiplies.
And that's one thing at the start so I will start with a very general not very satisfactory concept
but it's basically an object that takes stuff simple stuff from the outside as food and can make itself replicate.
And a fancy a way of saying it is a self-sustaining. It's a bit like a flame that can feed itself thing.
Basically that can evolve.
But let's make it even more precise and just say life is a non-trivial self-sustaining thing in a big universe.
Now let me there's a couple of scientific leap. So non-trivial means that it's not like sand. It's complicated.
That means that you'd have to write down some lines in a book to write down what it is.
Self-sustaining means it can keep going that non that complex. Keeps going.
So it's a bit like say the storm on Jupiter has been working around for these thousands of years in the universe. So.
Now can you see that life at that level to me has very little to do with chemistry and here is the problem.
Lots of people who are trying to make
or understand the origin of life are being very specific in their chemical archeology.
But I'm just looking for a process. So I want to make the simplest object that will self sustain itself.
Be complicated and go around the universe. So in my test tube I want to make a blob or a cell.
That is able to make itself when you feed it food.
And these complicated that just didn't just randomly arise because if I if I say life is salad dressing like I shake
some vinegar and some oil when I get you know nice little Samik vinegar and I get this nice looking thing.
Well that people say whether that looks like a life form but it doesn't make itself is not complicated.
It doesn't doesn't act on itself a higher level definition of life. What I like in the end is like.
Is one that can act on itself to change itself. What does that mean. Well I mail. I've got a headache. I can go.
And I can pick up a pill and take it and cure my headache.
So I can do something from the outside to the inside when you look in your environment. You don't think you don't see.
Dead things purposefully moving around. So we call this agency is almost a bit like a self-awareness.
So I sheep will go from grass to United to pasture to pasture a dog will go and follow its master or you know.
So there's like this. Inputs. But I think they're quite complicated things.
So I thought I do like this idea of a complex thing that self sustains in a big universe. So that that. Can also Yeah.
So it copies itself over time.
There's more of itself that basically take Rule materials and become more complicated
and I guess these no these are notions it's a bit like flight because everyone had a thought everyone tends to fight
about definitions of life because you know.
We thought we could make a list of things right needs to evolve like Darwinian Darwin right.
It needs to be based on carbon right. Nice to have water. Correct. Right.
Nice to have a certain And then you get right this list
and the problem is the list gets so long you forget why you're writing the list.
And so I go back to fly and say well what is interesting about flight will for me I want to get on my airplane.
I want to take off safely and travel several thousand miles touched our enemy. Get off refuel going. So although.
So flight means something to us.
So if I could make a new life form based upon different chemistry that would be really interesting because suddenly we
don't have to say it's based on carbon or water.
Because suddenly I'm now looking for a complex thing the self-sustaining and universe
but it doesn't have to be based on carbon or water.
And that's kind of where we're going at the moment and that is not a finished.
Definition and it may never will be but think back to before flight before airplanes.
We didn't have anything else to reference now we could all agree if we went to see some objects you know parachutist
or whatever. What would be a lot of what would be flying or not.
So I'm hoping that if we can make new life forms of different chemistry. It would help us under identify new life.
Maybe there's other life forms on the earth very. Simple that we don't understand.
We haven't recognized because they're too simple. We just ignore them for this very bad. Yes.
I would I would say potentially but maybe not.
I think maybe not but what we're doing is they're just prove you're right.
Well I think there's a very important question.
But what we're trying to do so many people are not are saying we need to design
or we need to select a very special chemistry and only a very special chemistry gay it can lead to life and biology.
So the very special chemistry living or origin of life and biology. I'm trying to say the other way around.
Maybe the process is more important than the chemistry and the process selects the chemistry and he's become alive.
Now Bearing that in mind. Suddenly we go to the lab now we suddenly free. We don't just have to use D.N.A.
Amino acids the things that you find the biology we can use sand when you salt. We can use other stuff.
So what we're trying to do is to take the simplest molecules the simplest chemicals and shake them together
and look for evidence that they would become complicated. To start to become self-sustaining.
We want to look for phenomena like forming.
Cells would look for making machines look for evidence of complexity
and so if I could basically take some very simple molecules and they would turn themselves into a cell.
That could self replicate and look like a bacterial cell under a microscope then that would be really interesting
and one of the. Well if you find them like this you know I'm no I don't know what Mo what so.
No I don't have any clue
but I think I'm right because I think well if I think if you think back to the the Earth early Earth was really crazy.
Like every day that goes by. There's fire.
There's brimstone those asteroids hitting the water's being evaporated there's lava coming out the energy is really
high. So any really sexy sophisticated chemistry will be raised in a second or would be a raised.
And this is my pick for me. That I saw you know maybe when I when I think about because I obviously like.
Water because I'm in Scotland and it's raining all the time but you look at the river or in the sea
and you look at patterns and things and they're only there for a small moment in time.
So if the pattern was going to be a raised really quickly. Life is a pattern that doesn't get raised it takes.
The outside and makes a pattern the makes more of itself and replicates that pattern
and life is a bit like the Olympic flame.
It's that that organization that goes from thing to thing to thing in time
and space that never gets erased because it keeps being replicated.
So if that could happen on earth I reasoned it has to be a happen much easier than we thought because otherwise the
complex chemistry would be erased by the meteorite the water boiling the fire and brimstone some ice simple notion.
If I'm being brutally honest really honest is that I don't pin really on this because I don't have any cognitive
reserve is that I feel that life is far simpler than we could possibly imagine
and I think we can recreate it in lots of different chemistries and there's no secret.
There was lots of origins of life on planet Earth. One origin of biology that we know today. It's.
Lots of roots there lots of ways to make a life form and they all converged and they cooperate
and they ended up with D.N.A. and Proteins and ourselves as a compromise if you like between all the different.
Extremes. You know. Minidisc player ipod tape cassette all these different technologies that were competing.
It was the same in chemistry I think I believe I only say I believe I guess is a belief because it believes of those
things that can't yet be test.
And obviously I'm trying to turn that belief into a scientifically falsifiable set of experiments.
And so we're going from two extremes.
What I talk about top down with a robot doing it in the bottom up allowing it to happen and then videoing it.
So that's what we're looking for we're looking for the simplest chemistry the can show evidence of becoming
self-sustaining. And complex. So it's a bit like how simply can we make a fire.
Able to go and find its own fuel but this fire has a pattern maybe it's not just a flame but it's a word
and they say the word fire let's say the word fire can write fire and that word word fire became Pepco from.
And that's what we're looking for in the lab. If that analogy makes sense you could try to think of a better way.
Mason is very very very very right.
Because of what was there and I'll leave you with this because of this element of complexity.
So complex it is and then all these other courses and. Values all rules. So very much. But how do you. OK.
He's got this. So I was just thinking about it.
I was taught when you were talking as there is like extreme trial and error.
I'll tell you something which I found when the most beautiful things are done as a parent
or my wife was done as a parent it was a gift we were given. Which was basically grow your own butterfly.
And so you have this kit where you have these things that turn in the capital and have them food and they go around
and you watch them go for the process the caterpillars eat the food.
They then make chrysalis and you put them in a you know they're all net and they go up.
And they're ready and after some time the butterflies come out but when we did it. We had five.
And we were really a motion the attacks and the kids are like look at this buffalo is coming
but the fifth one got tangled in its way. It's like silk. And it never made it free.
It died and we were so what we try to cut it free and grew so upset
but they were like ah that's the perfect thing about life. It's trial and error. Those that survive continue.
And if you think about. Trial and Error life is nothing more than matter that helps itself through trial and error.
And is a bit like the selfish gene but it's more primal than that it's more simple. And support simply.
What is the simplest sand or dirt or rocks that can help other rocks get better. And what is the definition of better.
The problem with life that all the nice thing about life is you were talking earlier and it's complicated.
Now but for something to be alive.
It has to die and there's a kind of simple thing you will know when and let's say a bacterium is alive it's dead
when it's dead it's no longer able to grow reproduce. You know with the bacteria if you feed it food.
Every twenty minutes it splits into two into two into two
and it's really interesting that that point of a bacterium this is imagine a bacterium
and then in twenty minutes does this.
So I ask you a question in your in your in your stomach in your intestine you have lovely bacteria that look after you
or you have your bacteria whatever you want to call them your micro biome How old are the bacteria in your intestine.
Area. I would say roughly three point nine billion years.
Because that bacteria came from one bacteria that came from one bacteria came and there is
and the limb picked thoughts of information passed back to what we called Luca the last universal common ancestor.
In that wonderful the last universal common ancestor.
It's from the cell from which all other cells on earth originated. It's that Olympic torch. That was then copied.
But now wasn't just one of them picked taught it was carried from athlete to athlete they copied it. It was a bit like.
Then suddenly copying a photograph or I don't know a a something that goes viral on the Internet.
Everyone watching it so that bacteria in your intestine. Is. Billions of years old.
You are billions of years old because where do you come from you come from your parents whether they come from their
parents where they come from and then and for evolution before then maybe from their primates
and then from there for that and all the way back. Is interesting that you persist in time but you die.
And so
and the case different from bacteria because they never quite die they they're like they split into two split into two
but it's a change in cycle.
So this is trial and error and so it's another way of summing up what's the minimum trial
and error I can set up to carry on going. And I still I don't know I mean to be are you.
You know what it means people say well what is it Michael. I kind of know what I'm looking for or know when I see it.
But what I need to do right now is start with really simple chemistry in the lab.
And I need to wash it like a hawk into suddenly something really odd happens and I go there.
The events those events are responsible for the origin of life or maybe a new life form
and so I guess it's really that is it. I mean what I'm doing exactly extrude remotely simple.
I'm just playing dice keep rolling the dice rolling the dice.
I want basically not just to get one six but six sixes in a row and then I want to keep going
and I want to preserve the motion I'm the last play to get those six sixes in a row. OK so. Becky. How is your life.
I mean I like you. Oh yeah yeah yeah. So we have a game or two ways.
I because I do a lot of inorganic chemistry you want to get it to I I assemble really complex molecules from simple
molecules and and the way I do this is I add acid to salt.
And normally it's boring but in my lab we can make it be interesting.
So that's what we're doing right now is we're looking at how to make the most complicated molecules with the least
instructions.
And with the robot the same we are giving it some chemistry to do
but we're saying what about if we give you the least instructions what is the most interesting thing you can do with
the least instructions and then when it does nothing. We should does at the moment say OK I give in.
I give you the full instructions. What happens when you have all the instructions what can you then do.
And then that's what we've done
and we would show you this in the Brits have made a robot that you can give instructions
and it makes really complex oil droplets that look like they're alive but they're not alive. They just move a lot.
They were orchestrated it was a cheat a set up a bribe whatever. But then we say OK because we couldn't.
When we know what instructions we needed to do to make the droplets look alive.
How can we now move the information from the robot to the. Chemistry and it's a bit like this.
We are saying we want the robot to write Shakespeare or the equivalent complex poetry song.
Now because of robots dumb it doesn't know Shakespeare so we have to tell it Shakespeare so it just copies it
and then if we blot out certain amounts of Shakespeare we say OK write Shakespeare with this small fragments.
And they would say right OK Now you know know Shakespeare but learn a little bit of English
and see if you can make something that sounds like Shakespeare what you need to go for it to make that
and I think that's that's what we're trying to do I know it sounds kind of intangible is like still you kind of expect
to me now. What we are doing in the lab which is even to start somewhere that.
What we are doing in the lab to start somewhere. Simple as you say right.
Biology is made up with carbon nitrogen oxygen hydrogen sulfur
and some other metals what we're doing is we're putting these elements together and whiz up in them with electricity
and we're heating them with them. What do they form. So we're taking hydrogen me thing ammonia and water.
And we're doing a very classic experiment was first done in the night in fifty's called the million year experiment
and they got two electrodes to simulate lightning and they got this simple. Soup and they heated it.
Very simple very simple elements very simple molecules and what they got when they did it
and they did it for four five days that in the end in that soup in the primordial soup they got some oil.
So it looked like loopy crude oil but they saw some acids in it some molecules look like amino acids
and they got really excited because I'm you know acids are what you find in biology in your proteins they are the
simplest molecules. So when are the problem is solved. Just me for a nitrogen. You know so I'm just me.
Fane and hydrogen an ammonia and some flame and some fire and you can make amino acids.
But those amino acids are really simple and they're in really low concentrations there's a very small amount.
So even though people have tried to since the night in fifty's were almost the last sixty five sixty six years people
tried to turn those amino acids into pro teams and they have failed.
What we've just done in the last year is we've made a robot that takes a simple Zimmy no acids
and does random chemistry with amino acids and we've seen how primitive proteins can emerge.
Or they're not proteins I must be honest. They're protein like but they can emerge from the random chemistry.
Oh yeah we have a clue. And we used a robot to do it and I realized the question you're asking for survival.
Like what you need sand and border sand on board of salt. What are you doing.
Hydrogen carbon ammonia some flame amino acids really simple building blocks those building blocks.
We then put into a robot to basically shake in a different way this very important thing is that we.
Then take the material from the million year experiment which is just in a. In a in a vessel.
And we
and you then algorithm to order the to simulate lots of different environments because in a bell jar there was no sand
there is no crust. It was just it was sanitized it was dead.
It wasn't complicated enough the earth was quite complicated there minerals that's a surface that there was some
atmosphere. So what we did is we put everything into different building blocks so it.
Start again we put everything into different vessels and we treated it different way.
So we did lots of random experiments and we looked for organization.
So what we did was we made a massively parallel miliary combination. So we took the building blocks in the middle.
And we divided it into literally a thousand different pots.
This is like how do you make a cake from random recipe random ingredients Well you could randomly follow them go
interest do one another and you make nothing or you could get somewhere where you make it go
and then you say OK I'll put it into a thousand cake pots and put them in the oven and see which rise
and select the ones which rise night and look nice and that's what we did. So like. Yeah it's exactly an enigma.
You are. This is really good. So here's the thing.
The Enigma Machine was a code breaking machine
and I look like the origin of life is an enigma machine the code the code that came from the enemy was in the
environment everyone can see it. But the sequence. The D.N.A. If you like was not known.
So we had to happen to find that random code by guessing or to plug it in we plug it in we know the solution instantly.
Or if we guess we have to take many many goats and that's exactly it.
You could view the origin of life like an Enigma machine. And we just do not know the cipher. We don't know the key.
Sorry to type in
and actually I said this I said is to complex if arest he's interested in decryption encryption he said yes right.
In fact if we know all the program on Earth.
By knowing the life form or knowing how we can work backwards and work out the keys.
And it's a bit like how you do encryption today. So you could do it like that.
And so life suddenly even on a chemist life suddenly takes on a meaning that is not based in chemistry.
It's information. What about what is now the magic information I can give you to go away and build a whole new society.
So I sent you to Mars which one book which you take to make oxygen water.
Have you seen the Martian maybe we should talk about films on this on the scene so.
He's an interesting thing in the end the way human beings explain escape planet Earth is that they will send out robots
that will go to other planets.
And they will look for a source
and they would turn that resource into a living hour of them to make more of itself to make a living machines
and that's what we'll do. I guess. Make sure that you go in there and you know cook correct then to cheering.
Well I mean a lot of the work we're doing is inspired by cheering I mean cheering. Given what has happened today.
I'm not sure I want to talk of cheering and Boltzmann but I've committed suicide.
Both men committed suicide because no one understood what he was talking about
and was really shunned by the environment by the society cheering committed suicide for reasons or complicated.
He was homosexual he was victimized he was bullied he was pushed out he had many way.
But cheering really inspired both cheering and Boltzmann inspired me not because they committed suicide
but because they really had very interesting handles on a very complex problem. Boltzmann talked about disorder.
He knew about randomness. And he worked out this thing this measure of randomness called entropy.
Basically my kids when they go into their bedroom they go. And if the entropy is high. It.
If it's very random they've worked hard and made it random it's like what happens when he goes out if I go in
and I order everything the ID Creasy entropy.
So I then the nice thing when I decrease the entropy I give it a chance to be disordered Ika.
Cheering understood this also.
But in a different way he came up with an idea called morphogenesis and when I go running now
when I'm thinking for years for me.
What is inspired me and drives me and I think that because of course everyone says to me sometimes
when they're making fun. I don't have any original ideas.
I'm desperate to have an original idea maybe I haven't yet it's just a synthesis of other people's ideas for me I want
to come up with chemistry that undergoes morphogenesis.
So if I get a movie Genesis is like I'm an object that can change shape and change function but still be there
but still be it itself.
And I guess what are say to me maybe the viewer is like what is what defines yourself you would go out
and look at a rock and say oh that's a self but you would go out and look at a deer or go or a child
or an animal say oh that's a self that controls a living thing is a thing which can then actually observe.
Itself and walk and talk and move.
It's not only that because bacteria can't walk and talk and move in the same way they certainly move
but it's more crude.
So there is something interesting about what shearing thought about and decryption decryption and computers
and robots and so on
and in the end I'm pretty sure that human beings will be a make a robot that will be a make itself but and
but I'm anxious that we don't forget the origin of life.
Because one day maybe Rob Well maybe he's a story this imagine the human beings are long gone
and there are only robots.
And the robots make themselves and the robots go to another planet and there's a robot society
and there's a supernova that raises the memory and the robot is forget where they come from where we come from.
So they start the origin of robot life the grinding silicon chips up and because like where did the chip come from.
It's not self assembling and they forgot.
That they're a complex machine made by a more simple machine made by a more simple machine.
And so if I can tell you anything today which I think for me I can't really justify
but my feeling is life started with a minimal machine that can make a slightly more complicated machine that can make a
slightly more complicated machine and so yes is turtles all the way down
but they're simpler until the search the turtle right at the bottom is just sand and water and at the end we have.
I don't know pornography.
Well because art you know this is I can say I mean one of my friends who's looking at Robo Cop culture loss the
ultimate. The ultimate form of a robot culture will be robot pornography that they all share.
Maybe you don't want to put this in the main movie I don't know the main documentary.
But I think your comment about cheering is very perceptive. I'm certainly inspired by him.
I'm certain inspired by a lot of people that look to informatics I think one
and I'm one of the third synthetic chemists to be sufficiently inspired by information
and say How can I do the minimum. How can I come up with a minimum information but get the maximum chemistry.
And whether the things we're doing and where we're going and how I kind of got to this is.
We're trying to discover new drugs in my lap and make new drugs
and if the viewer is completely confused about molecules and drugs and life.
I'll give you one interesting thing I don't know if you know about the antibiotic problem.
Can and are can be the drug they can out of Alvi using natural selection the drug doesn't use natural selection.
So it relies on the human being to make a new drug in my lab one of the reasons why we want to make an artificial life
form is if we can make drugs that are in competition with the bacteria and we say right.
Here's a new but here's a new bacteria. Here's a new drug dead.
Oh no of all of it and all we do now is there's no such thing as antibiotic.
There's only a generation of new antibiotics that can be made under pressure. By the bacteria.
So suddenly we change the entire concept of an adult a obsolescent drug no antibiotics become obsolete because we have
an evolutionary machine. So at the very worst what we have made in my lab is not very good.
So they get excited we haven't cured the problem
but we have made an evolution machine that starts to show us how we can make some drugs evolve
and be some antibiotics and when they are out of all the drugs we do it again and keep going
and what our dream is to make a machine. They can evolve an endless infinite pipeline of drugs.
And when we understand the process.
Maybe we can understand how the life got started because it's an information based argument.
You know I'm expressing myself Isn't it wonderful the universe exists look at the glorious things that happen.
And one of the reasons why I'm doing what I'm doing is because I get I'm paid to Haas why. Or OK.
Well isn't that a wonderful privilege. And that is one of the reasons why I try and engage. To tell people.
And why are trying not to be arrogant about it because I don't feel a sense of arrogance I feel.
I thought and where I come from is a sense of profound dumbness or a profound insecurity about understanding myself
and why I'm here and but I'm I like to be creative.
And so you know that's it's and it's a privilege to do it
but if I can come up with like we talked about the antibiotics earlier and society excuse.
Not to validate it but if I can turn the idea into something really cool that could change humanity or be useful.
Then I think that's really excellent. And one of the things as what I want is obviously better.
I want to solve the problem.
I want to make sure I'm useful and I want to understand more about the process
and so that it's all kind of in all complicated it's kind of what we're woven together. By one on one or one B. or.
All I know when I was at school and. That.
The teachers told me I was never going to really make it beyond anything I said you. Just not going to make it.
You're not smart. They used to they used to say you're pretending to be smart.
Stop pretending to be smart and those like will which means are you pretending to read my.
Pretending to do math that we don't understand or you're pretending that we got the book at the library
and they were like Stop trying to fool us like well surely it would be more effort to for you than just to do it.
So if I was successfully following you wouldn't that be mean I'm even smarter than just being a I do it
and they were like to go away.
So so I I think that's one of the reasons why I can deal with imposter syndrome a lot of people in science
or anything you're good at stuff athletes everybody. If I don't love us we're all impostors to some degree.
I mean do we feel good enough to know that's what we're trying to better.
And so I become comfortable about people telling me I'm not going to succeed. That doesn't mean I shouldn't try.
So that's their right and I say no one thinks I'm going to succeed to make a new life form in my laboratory.
I don't think you'll find anyone that believes I'm going to succeed but probably I will. And for the simple reason.
Not for the complicated one.
And the simple reason is because it's obvious and easy and not that complicated going on already.
And not for that I am this magician who knows something they don't and I'm so incredibly smart
and I'm this hidden genius that could clearly I'm not. But use. You all read my work.
While I made a mistake a few years ago when I gave a talk at taiji know
when you're trying to give this this TED Talks of the sound bite talks are privileged to give him great
but you you feel like you want to time the time time bound it
and I gave a time it would take once we knew what we were doing. I reckon we could do it quickly.
You know year few years. But then that that kind of got missed. Understood as all you do in two or three or four years.
I don't know. When we make progress in one two three four five ten years I would hope so. Can I put a limit on it.
No because I don't want to raise expectations
but I think right now it would be nice within the next ten years to know how hard the problem was.
It or there's a if I can't do it in a decade or two.
Or if I can't convince other people to help me because I think it's beyond me.
I am not capable of solving this problem on my own that's what I've realized.
But maybe I'm capable of building co-operative network to make a basically a large hadron collider of chemistry
and I make a chemical Internet so that all chemists can explain explain their chemistry to each other
and work together. If I can't do it but they can't do it and then so suddenly.
I then crowd source chemistry through all my other labs and my competitors become co-operative
and maybe that's a way of looking at it to turn it into a big corporate event and ever
and we realize it's beyond one of us right. Right yeah yeah.
Look I'm right I look like a OK if you want me to level with you. I can't tell you why I'm right I'm right.
And the job my job is you quite rightly as a skeptic should go. No actually you're not right into you demonstrate.
The theory the experiment and the critique and you carry on and you let everyone else judge
and your peers will judge if you're right you won't.
Your so in a way the nice thing for me is I like look I say I don't have to be right. I don't have to be wrong.
I just have to do it.
And I say here's my assumption here my experiments because you know what when people believe they're right
and they just think everyone else is you know. How dare you give me a critic criticism.
I'm right you're just too stupid to understand or you don't understand this
or you don't know that there's something wrong. I see this all the time.
So my job is to say on Asli as much as possible. Here are my starting points here. My rules for my experiment.
Now are firm I die. Look how the experiment unfolds and all I want you to do is go wow that's interesting.
If I can get you to do that doesn't matter. I'm right or wrong I will take a holiday or. It.
Glory in discovery all I want to do more than anything else.
The reason I'm doing this for a reason I think I'm right is I want to discover the process or the the phenomenon
or the thing that it is that turns.
Dead chemistry to live in chemistry enough for me so I suppose I know I'm going to discover something is probably more
what I can say with certainty rather than I know I'm right.
And that's what I guess I'm trying to say to be and in the end I don't know if I'm right.
Maybe I will never be proven right or wrong in my lifetime because.
We won't have the tools or I am I is an image
but I lack the the intellect maybe I'm smart enough maybe the computers aren't fast enough.
The time is not long enough.
But if I can start with sand and turn into an object the starts to do something by itself when I feed it a field
and you go wow this look at that again
and you see that spark of life in that previously dead object that's really cool.
What I think I might have been able to do.
Is when they spark in life to set up those sparks of life those living things can do stuff that dead things can't do.
And they make artefacts a bit like a caveman or me.
Would make a complex object if you found in your backyard a thousand years later.
Well naturally occurring or someone made that.
I think I have come up with a thing an algorithm as I would call it a measure of made up ness.
If I showed you a thing an object. You could tell me using my rules whether a living system a life form made it or not.
And that is what I'm most excited about right now because that seems to be working in my head
and I'm challenging it to all the skeptics I can find and they are trying to demolish it right now
and I think they will get somewhere but there's something in it and your year to worry or you're right on time.
You can cut that out.
Depending on whether it works or not and a year's time and I think that in a year's time we will know.
So if you bring me an object and. If you go to him if I go to Mars.
He's my phone and you can see my phone's screen because my boys when they're young at the dentist
and I find this on Mars. What you conclude if you go to Mars.
You're the first person on Mars and you find one of these phones. What do you conclude.
There you know is either a hoax I'm not the first one or a life form made a phone can't. It's why the one or the other.
So now let's say we go to Mars and we find an object the so complicated. It doesn't exist on Earth.
We've never seen it before is not an it's not evidence of Apple going galactic
or so that was the solar system like solar Apple solar You heard it here. You know I just want I want money from Apple.
I want. To pay me to go solar there may be a long bus can do that.
If so if you can find a complicated enough these are called bio signatures.
And what I've done is I think I've started to use it after written a new complexity theory me which I'm very proud of
is that someone in school who was never any good at math apparently Well I'm obviously not that I've written a new
complexity theory with my research team.
And it seems to give us biasing machines to tell us when something is as complicated or improbable as a phone.
You bring me a molecule in your hand.
I can tell you by doing a number of simple things that molecule if it was made by a life form or not.
How cool is that Equally if you say this house was this house made by a life form or not. Yes. Your car your phone.
So now I have now got a hierarchy of complexity and now in the end I can define complexity by life by complexity.
The necessary complexity is a bit like life form or that life is those things that can fro six die six sixes in a row.
Every time you know if you just want it possible for you this go.
This mathematics or this explanation for four out of a ninety dollars life or.
Not intelligence evidence of come out of a life form not intelligence. Here's a way I did it. OK. It is it right.
Cold or not. You know.
No it's more is even more brilliant than that
when I should say that it's even more simple than that I don't want to sound narcissistic on camera. It's even.
More simple than the code. Because a code requirement. Already he said that molecules. It's more courses.
And so Amalek than a know any molecule So if you bring a molecule to me.
I don't want to give too much away it's not published yet
but people should be thought it should be published will go well.
I guess it's out there looking for something where you are drawing you all on your own.
There is a fresh old there is a multi So here's the thing.
When you add sand together you get certain patterns and you get those patterns will be simple.
It's basically how many grains of sand I have to learn to get or to get a pattern that is not randomly possible
and that is the beginning of the code in molecules if you imagine sand grains or atoms.
When you fire them together they join. They'll be a certain pattern of atoms that when joined together.
If you can find that in the environment. That cannot spontaneously form because it's just too improbable.
And that is it all. I think. And I'm super excited because now I don't need to make life. Just make life.
I need to make the simplest machine that can make the most complicated molecule.
So now I'm like our I don't have to fly for the sake of it because flying no one flew for the sake of it.
They flew because they wanted to be gravity and I want to get from London to New York. Now I have a reason.
For doing it. That's really important. I have a reason for doing it.
I can I can improve the complexity of the molecule.
And more importantly than that more important is I can look on earth while Mars or Europa.
And I can and I can see if I can find molecules on these planets.
That are greater than the fresh told of naturally occurring and to see if there is Martians or Europeans.
Because while I could argue that life on Earth is too sophisticated. So has become globalization..
Let me tell you the ultimate globalization in life on earth D.N.A. Everyone has it how we boring we all have D.N.A.
It's like McDonald's
or got McDonald's look at the Golden Arches you'll have to have a thing called a ribozyme a rubber zone is a machine it
turns your D.N.A. Information into the.
Proteins how boring is that everybody's been globalized on Earth we all use the same thing.
Wouldn't it be great if on Earth we found other life forms that didn't use D.N.A.
Would it be great if one Europa and on Mars. We found other life forms that didn't use D.N.A.
but They were still alive.
They were above this fresh old and the only way we could recognize them is they were making really complex molecules
and you talk about code the reason I got excited is.
The reason why some of my friends in complexity science or are excited is what normally when you take any code
or you take a picture you have to sign a code to it is abstract letters.
Well for me the code is written in the periodic table the code is solved by the process of quantum mechanics the code
is embedded in the laws of the universe. So their identity carbon or nitrogen oxygen or sulfur.
They are implicit The code is already there. I don't add it on.
So it means that the molecule that I think is complicated in on earth next to the sun.
He's equally valid in Alpha Centuri a planet next to that and is a universal code if the code of complex molecules so.
If I send a space probe to somewhere else in the universe and it finds a complex molecule.
And it's different to what we know on Earth then we can assume that it formed by chance Of which there is no chance.
I would explain that it's not just the take that's an assumption even if you don't believe me just say OK I will assume
that Lee's assumption is correct if this molecule couldn't form by chance. And isn't come from a.
A nother life or made it. That's it that's what we're looking for it's out. Really. Of course when you see. Thanks.
Well. Oh well that me. Us.
Well I think for me it will be if we succeed when we succeed
when we succeed it will tell us that the universe has the propensity the ability to live. And the we are not a fluke.
So that we can prove our highest huge sigh of relief to say you know why are our pathetic little lives has some meaning.
We are here. Now what meaning what we impose the meaning on ourselves the universe just is right.
I'm not looking for the meaning anywhere just is but then we can shift our entire problem to like saying OK.
Life is easy. What about complex life. How easy is that.
And let's just say someone along after I die it manages to do that and then say OK.
What about intelligence how do you make that and what does that mean. And by this mind blowing.
I mean I was so many steps I did.
I'm I'm I'm a real practical guy I'm a chemist I love computers the reason why I got you know my son is nine years old.
My oldest son. And last Saturday I did something that my father did for me when I was nine years old.
He bought me a computer.
So I took my son
and I bought in the Raspberry Pi which is the well the the brick the best selling British computer ever
and I have to be true to British computer science because it's a legend.
I had a six a one I bought him this reply we had a nice case of the keyboard so he took his programming basic he's
addicted this hilarious.
And one of the things I loved about when I grew up you know
when I was nine ten eleven years old that the teachers were saying I was stupid.
but I was programming I was using assembly and trying to get as many programs into one K.
I was fascinated I needed one killer by how much mayhem could I cause with one killer bike..
So for me it was like compression. How could I compress as much potential mayhem in one K.
And that's why I became obsessed with complex ability complexity ability. That's a new word compression and complexity.
How much mayhem can I. Compact into a small box. How do you. You get yourself. On.
Going crazy because all of us have years. That is like life. Diet pills. Well I mean thinking about this.
Just balance your. I've always been balance from the beginning. I'm always a little bit on there.
The weird side in terms of I'm a little bit extrovert but
but my family my I may sound my family came before my science. OK I mean all I care.
Talk about as a child but my progress into academia.
I was married before I was a professor I was married before then and my wife is one of the smartest people I know
and she kind of he said this may. Yeah why ever. Now go. Do the washing up or.
Yeah you may be smart because she has appears the in fundamental mind ism.
So it's kind of grounding in a way in magnetism quantum magnetism.
So she was trying to understand how little magnets could order and undergo phase transitions.
And long distance and so and you know like me she was an interesting.
She was she was opposite at school she was in a poor school
but the genius at school so you know thought she walked on water.
So she was told she was a genius when I was told I was in my own genius at school.
So I don't know and we met we met on a crystallography course Actually one.
Course which is like a science course understanding X. Ray diffraction. Years and years ago. I don't know. I suppose.
I've never been I'm out there real chemistry I guess I mean.
I don't know there's something intrinsically grounded in my prime of practice it's practical.
I think the I guess he's the reason why it's grounded it's all very practical.
It's like a lot of people go crazy because it becomes more and more abstract
and like oh you can't possibly understand how complicated it is in my head and all this and yet probably you can
and probably you can but at the end of the day
and this is why one of the things I'm doing my research group at the most I'm really privileged to have some really
smart people. And their challenge. There I probably can't use the word retard.
In America or somebody says the stupid person in the group is me. If they can explain to me what they've done.
I can't write the paper with them
and I can't raise the money with them because I'm not just sitting in my office waiting for a paper
and waiting for money. I want to do my science I'm addicted to chemistry. I mean what do you do that.
Well I mean I'm going I'm going to balance. Your own life. Yeah well it's very practical use.
You know everyone said I mean a few weeks ago I remember being interviewed by someone else the same question I used to
have a listening idea or this
and I was like how they do anything else I sleep four hours a day I work the rest spend some time with family
and it's not quite as severe as all that but what I'm saying let me finish one point the first point is very practical.
So the problems are very practical like you're having deep thoughts and then your glass breaks
and there's water everywhere in this crap everywhere it's like you've got it. You've got to clean it up.
That's one thing. At home. Well I like to watch television with my wife we like fiction. I run every day.
And I've got two kids and I like to do stuff with them and I like them to challenge me and
and as much as I'm always busy because I'm trying to raise money and writing papers and like that.
C'mon you know they're getting older.
They're only going to be this age for a little while
and so I was fortunate enough to have children a time in my life where everything could have gone off the rails.
But they bring you back. There's nothing a like a kid vomiting on your shoulder or telling you you know you come here.
You come in was a brilliant idea. And we could just go in there. Not interesting.
And it's quite funny because I like they don't know.
OK OK to me one of them says something odd that they're smart and that just really interesting
and I'm interested in them. But so. I've been hobbies Well I do a lot.
I love computers I love technology I love hacking around.
Well yeah I mean the fact is I mean you're trying to say that I you know pain or handle I don't I don't. I just.